un año de una decisión que suprimió los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de las
mujeres estadounidenses el 24 de junio
de 2022 la Corte Suprema de mayoría
conservadora anuló la sentencia del caso
Row versus White de 1973 que permitía a
las mujeres abortar libre y legalmente
desde entonces al menos 20 estados
tienen prohibiciones casi totales o
nuevas leyes que limitan el acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
debido a estas restricciones Amanda
residente de Texas estuvo a punto de
morir por un aborto involuntario
es exasperante y dicen que lo hacen
porque son provida Pero no entiendo que
tiene esto de provida porque estuve a
punto de morir porque están en riesgo
las vidas de mis futuros bebés
con la nueva normativa cientos de
clínicas tuvieron que cerrar el personal
sanitario y los médicos de atención
materna de los estados restrictivos se
enfrentan a la disyuntiva de renunciar a
sus trabajos o ir nuestros estados por
miedo a ser condenados
los riesgos de ser acusado de un delito
grave los riesgos reales de prisión y
cómo se vería eso para mi familia y para
mi carrera y todo lo que habíamos
trabajado tan duro para construir
con la prohibición vigente ya no pudimos
brindar el estándar de atención la
medicina más basada en evidencia para
ciertas complicaciones del embarazo
Porque se consideró ilegal
Pese a que las activistas defensoras de
derechos humanos han alertado que este
retroceso en materia de derechos pone en
riesgo la vida de miles de mujeres los
grupos religiosos y conservadores
republicanos aspiran a más y buscan
prohibir también los métodos
anticonceptivos la píldora abortiva o
los viajes entre Estados para abortar
por ello el viernes el presidente Joe
biden firmó una nueva orden ejecutiva
para proteger el acceso anticonceptivos
entre otras cosas Las aseguradoras
privadas deberán cubrir la mayoría de
los costos de estos medicamentos